one patient Philip is an amateur
Puppeteer so Freddy enters his dream and
turns him into a human puppet using his
veins as strings marching him to a third
floor window and cutting him loose
causing him to fall to his death in both
the dream and the real world probably
the most disturbing and creative kill in
all of Freddy's history the next night
he goes after Jennifer an aspiring TV
star and pulls her head through the TV
in her room [__] the F time yeah it
turns out to be Freddy who shoves his
giant tongue down the kid's throat then
uses it to restrain him above the bed
which Falls away into a giant pit of
fire it's always the tongue with this
guy I swear I could do a whole video on
just the history of Freddy Krueger's
tongue I'm getting flashbacks to the
Grimace video at this point it once
again hints at the two themes that I
keep coming back to Freddy is implied to
be a predator through his actions and
he's associated with the Devil by
suspending Joey over what is essentially
a pit to hell no not into the pit it
burns meanwhile all the other patients
are together in the group session
discovering how they can be whoever they
want to in their dream